c'est l'heure de notre second débat
comme chaque soir on prend du recul vous
le savez on sort de l'actualité du jour
pour prendre le temps de creuser un
thème de société ce soir l'avenir de
Twitter depuis son rachat par Elon Musk
licenciement de 3500 salariés fuite des
annonceurs réintégration de Donald Trump
et de 62000 comptes bannis pour de
multiples infractions le milliardaire
met-il en péril son réseau social et
puis c'est beaucoup plus vaste que ça le
fonctionnement de nos démocraties avant
d'en débattre le point sur une crise qui
dure depuis le 27 octobre avec Jonathan
Dupriez
c'est une nouvelle ère qui s'ouvre pour
Twitter le réseau social racheté au mois
d'octobre par le milliardaire Elon Musk
semble bouleverser ses principes jusqu'à
renier certaines de ses règles dernier
revirement en date la plateforme ne fera
plus la chasse aux fausses informations
sur le covid-19
du 23 novembre 2022 Twitter n'applique
plus
le regardant les informations trompeuses
sur le covid-19 ces dernières semaines
le réseau social basé à San Francisco
semble s'enfoncer dans une grave crise
interne Elon Musk a brutalement licencié
la moitié des effectifs de la plateforme
quelques 3500 salariés une décision qui
laisse planer le doute sur la stabilité
technique de la plateforme à court terme
autre décision ayant défrayé la
chronique celle de rétablir certains
comptes supprimés au nom de la liberté
d'expression un choix décidé par un
simple sondage des utilisateurs le
peuple a parlé l'amnistie débute la
semaine prochaine vox populi voxdi car
emblématique Donald Trump pourrait de
nouveau se créer un compte l'ancien
président américain avait définitivement
été suspendu de Twitter en 2021 pour y
avoir incité ces partisans à envahir le
Capitole
mais à ce stade l'ancien président
américain ménage le suspense sur un
éventuel retour
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait un grand
sondage sur un retour sur Twitter je ne
m'en préoccupe pas pour le moment je ne
vois pas pourquoi je reviendrai ils ont
beaucoup de problèmes chez Twitter
peut-être que ça passera peut-être que
ça ne passera pas ils ont des problèmes
considérables
entre coups budgétaire de grandes
incertitudes planent désormais sur
l'avenir du réseau social déficitaire de
longue date en 2021 Twitter a perdu 220
milliards de dollars contre seulement 5
milliards de recettes avec ces méthodes
jugées brutales Elon Musk prétend
toujours vouloir relever la plateforme
les invités de notre second débat tout
de suite Martin décidrac bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice LRD des
Yvelines vice-présidente du groupe
numérique au Sénat Thomas Huchon bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste investigations
spéciales du numérique auteur de ce
livre anti fake news écrit avec
Jean-Bernard Schmitt et publié aux
éditions
également Nicolas vanbremer je bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes le président du sing
tank du cercle de réflexion Renaissance
numérique et Mathieu croissanto est
resté à mes côtés rebonsoir Mathieu bon
je rappelle le prix d'achat Twitter
quand même 44 milliards de dollars posés
sur la table par Elon Musk pour pour
racheter le réseau social est-ce que
alors peu question très générale pour
commencer est-ce que voilà le le
l'arrivée d'Elon musk ce qui fait
Twitter depuis un peu plus d'un mois
est-ce que ça vous inquiète
inquiétez peut-être un peu fort
attendant de voir mais en tout cas c'est
interpelle oui ça interpelle ça
nécessite un petit peu de je dirais un
regard un peu plus
pointu sur ce qui se passe sur Twitter
aujourd'hui et puis notamment de quelle
manière cela va évoluer en fait c'est
surtout ça donc pour le moment je on va
voir
éventuellement
en détail un peu plus tard dans ce débat
Thomas on va faire un un petit peu de
pédagogie pour noter les spectateurs qui
n'utilisent pas Twitter il y en a
certainement peut-être vous pouvez nous
rappeler de quoi il s'agit et pourquoi
c'est c'est un réseau social important
aussi mais grosso modo on dit que
facebook c'est le média de l'archive
Twitter c'est le média de l'instant ça
veut dire que c'est l'endroit où on va
regarder ce qui se passe quand ça se
passe et c'est devenu depuis une dizaine
une quinzaine d'années et bien un lieu à
la fois d'information un lieu de
discussion politique un lieu de débat de
polémique et si ce réseau social compte
beaucoup moins d'utilisateurs que les
principaux si on prend Facebook c'est 3
milliards d'utilisateurs Instagram un
milliard Tik Tok 1 milliard Twitter ce
ne sont que 300 millions de personnes
mais 300 millions de personnes qui
pèsent dans les sociétés dans les pays
dans lesquelles ils évoluent souvent des
personnalités influentes souvent des
personnalités influantes on va retrouver
bien entendu des politiques on va
retrouver des journalistes on va
retrouver des spécialistes de questions
spécifiques en l'occurrence là on a un
spécialiste du numérique c'est pas
totalement
aberrant qu'il soit aussi sur Twitter et
les réseaux sociaux mais effectivement
c'est devenu à la fois une source
d'information un lieu de débat et c'est
devenu pour les vieux médias pour les
médias professionnels traditionnels et
bien une manière aussi de prendre le
pouls de l'actualité attention sur
Twitter tout ce qui fait le buzz n'est
pas toujours un buzz naturel ça veut
dire qu'il y a aussi beaucoup d'acteurs
qui vont utiliser ce qu'on appelle des
bottes donc des ordinateurs des machines
pour pousser des remontées des
thématiques dans la conversation
générale et donc Twitter c'est à la fois
un lieu de la réalité et puis c'est un
lieu où il y a des fake news où il y a
des choses qui sont absolument gonflées
de manière artificielle c'est un réseau
social finalement qui ressemble un peu
aux autres Thomas Vander c'est aussi un
outil de travail quoi il faut dire ça
alors pas seulement pour les
journalistes mais notamment pour les
journalistes Twitter en fait dans
l'architecture des réseaux sociaux et du
web Twitter je joue un rôle assez clé
c'est un rôle centripète un rôle qui
connecte qui rassemble un rôle d'Agora
d'espace public le plus possible les
autres ont plutôt des tendances à être
dans des microcommunautés de dispersion
etc qui posent des problèmes de
fragmentation de dispersion twitter est
un lieu de confrontation plutôt de
rassemblement ou les communautés
s'affrontent plutôt qu'elles ne se
rassemblent entre elles ou les médias
sont ensemble et un des problèmes de
Twitter fondamental que musk essaye de
résoudre ou qu'il a révélé c'est que on
est sur un réseau social qui au bout de
14 ans n'avait toujours pas trouvé son
modèle économique n'avait pas
d'équilibre mais et où tout le monde
avait intérêt à participer à Twitter
mais personne ne payait Public Sénat a
sûrement un compte Twitter j'ai un
compte Twitter j'ai jamais payé
vous non plus personne entre nous on
avait un objet commun avec tous un
intérêt public à utiliser ça mais qui
était fondé sur un équilibre économique
très très précaire ou auquel on n'était
pas responsabilisés
non plus oui mais ils ont trouvé un
modèle publicitaire beaucoup plus
costaud et bon bah c'est Madame michut
c'est du ciblage publicitaire tac tac
tac je parle de un sujet je suis ciblage
et de la pub sur Twitter on a une
fonction d'espace public et on a une
mais on n'est pas prêt à y participer
avec mes étudiants elle Sciences Po une
expérience qui est de télécharger les
données personnelles que Twitter a
amassé sur nous donc moi par exemple
quand je fais ça et ben je découvre que
je suis ciblé par une une marque
d'électronique qui fait soi-disant
attention aux questions de vie privée
parce que je suis la page de la CNIL la
Commission Nationale Informatique et
Liberté et donc il y a aussi sur Twitter
une forme de de profil de votre identité
numérique qui est réalisée et sur lequel
Twitter va gagner de l'argent avant ça
des annonceurs vous l'avez rappelé sur
internet quand c'est gratuit c'est vous
le produit et sur Twitter aussi
peut-être que ce réseau social n'a pas
trouvé comme d'autres la manière de
monétiser dans un deuxième temps cet
aspect donnait personne alors l'aspect
Agora dont vous nous parlez c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il y a un enjeu démocratique
intéressant
dans ce débat et dans le rachat de
Twitter par Elon Musk pourquoi ce
milliardaire qui a enchaîné les succès
avec avec Tesla avec le spatial avec
SpaceX pourquoi rachète-t-il Twitter
cette analyse d'une plateforme
d'investissement britannique à sa petite
idée on l'écoute
majeur il est très utilisé par les
journalistes et il joue un rôle
déterminant dans le fonctionnement de
l'ensemble des médias de nos jours
beaucoup d'informations sont partagées
sur Twitter beaucoup de nouvelles de
dernière minute et les journalistes
obtiennent une grande partie de leur
piste et de leurs sources grâce à
Twitter
il n'est donc pas surprenant que la
prochaine frontière qu'un milliardaire
boy franchir soit les médias
conseille dans le passé des réseaux
sociaux on peut on peut influencer le le
cours d'une élection notamment aux
États-Unis est-ce que c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il faut surveiller de près ce qui
se passe sur Twitter aujourd'hui et ce
qui va se passer dans les prochaines
semaines
j'ai presque envie de dire ça c'est la
partie visible de l'iceberg parce que
lorsque cela arrive à cette échelle là
évidemment tout le monde suit ça de près
on leur relève vous voyez on en parle
encore moi je crois que la raison réelle
pour laquelle il faut qu'on suivent de
près les les différents réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui on parle de Twitter mais
dans une certaine mesure c'est valable
pour les autres réseaux sociaux aussi
c'est un petit peu ce qui a déjà été à
évoquer c'est l'individu c'est à dire
nous tout un chacun de quelle façon nous
devenons soit produit vous avez parlé de
produits nous-mêmes soit influencé et
influenceurs donc tout cela il faut
faire attention parce que chacun de nous
dès lors que nous sommes sur les réseaux
nous avons notre petite communauté et
donc qu'est-ce que nous allons diffuser
dans cette communauté dès lors que nous
sommes vous voyez pour eux à ceux qui
nous viendrait d'ailleurs et ce ailleurs
justement n'est pas toujours très
clairement
identifié sur Twitter donc je pense que
c'est au-delà de d'élections qui
pourraient être
orienté suivi influencé
c'est plus sur le volet citoyen et donc
sur le volet démocratique en réalité
alors si vous les citoyens si vous
voulez démocratiques qui nous ramène à
la question de la modération on va dire
ça comme ça on va y consacrer un
chapitre entier mais je voudrais parler
maintenant de des premières
décisions d'Elon musk et peut-être on
nous a tous dit il va y avoir un risque
de panne de de Twitter il a licencié
plus de 3500 employés c'était à peu près
la moitié des effectifs Thomas Huchon
puis alors il en a perdu d'autres parce
qu'il a envoyé un mail on va dire
particulier il leur réclamait de
travailler de longues heures à haute
intensité bon il y a donc une un départ
de personnel assez important à quel
point ça met Twitter en péril qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait de ça mais déjà je crois
que ça révèle quand même une immense
brutalité dans la gestion
les gens qui ont été licenciés par Elon
Musk ont reçu un email avec un même de
Donald Trump dans l'émission The
apprentis dans lequel your five vous
êtes virés qui découvrait qu'ils étaient
licenciés dans un email avec une vidéo
de Trump qu'il se moquait d'eux quoi
donc il y a quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement violent d'extrêmement
brutal y compris pour la société
américaine dans lequel on sait que les
protections sociales sont pas exactement
les mêmes que notre pays donc il y a
déjà quand même une forme de de
contrôle à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
qui se fait et qui est quelque part un
peu inquiétant dans une société
démocratique dans une entreprise privée
il faut des contre-pouvoirs et en fait
le principal problème auquel va se
retrouver confronté Elon Musk c'est que
à force de de détruire tous les
contre-pouvoirs internes de se priver de
l'expérience et de l'expertise de tout
un tas de salariés une très compétent
qui travaillait parce qu'il a chez
Twitter vraiment viré aussi des des
cadres dirigeants
qui montrent bien un peu l'ambiance
qu'il y a chez Twitter il faut pas
oublier d'où viennent ces bonhommes là
Elon Musk c'est un des tenants de ce
qu'on appelle le paternalisme
libertarien c'est une philosophie
politique qui existe aux États-Unis qui
est un peu celle qui a irrigué la
Silicone Valley c'est une philosophie
qui dit que les êtres humains ne sont
pas capables d'atteindre le bien-être
seul et qu'il faut les y aider dit comme
ça on se dit bah tiens c'est peut-être
pas si grave si dangereux mais en
réalité ça dit quoi ça dit finalement il
y aurait un peu des super êtres humains
qui comprendraient ce qui est bien pour
les autres et puis d'autres qui
devraient obéir cette idée là appliquer
à un personnage comme Elon Musk qui a
non seulement une immense fortune mais
en plus un pouvoir
démesuré au sein de ces entreprises il y
a pas de contre-pouvoir Eden musk dans
les entreprises qui donnent musk il
ressemble un peu là dessus à Mark
Zuckerberg par exemple chez Google ou
chez Amazon les patrons ont une forme
d'actionnariat
n'est pas le leur c'est à dire que là on
a quelqu'un qui possède vraiment la
machine et qui peut faire ce qu'il veut
moi je suis un peu inquiet quand je vois
par exemple cette photo où on voit qu'il
a viré 50% des effectifs et bah sur une
photo on voit qu'il y a à peu près la
moitié de femmes dans la photo et puis
sur la deuxième photo il y a plus une
seule femme donc il y a aussi cette
espèce de logique un peu viriliste qui
est des tenants de la Silicon Valley
qu'on va retrouver et qui à mon avis est
très inquiétante et thomasch est-ce que
est-ce qu'il a déjà est-ce que il fait
toujours un peu la même chose Elon Musk
quand il prend possession d'une
entreprise il y a ce côté je vais dire à
la hussarde c'est presque trop sympa
mais voilà c'est c'est il y a le côté
provocateur ça on veut bien faire la
part des choses il y a la violence que
décrivait Thomas Huchon est-ce que c'est
son mode de fonctionnement je sais pas
il a pas un mode de fonctionnement
typique parce que à chaque fois il a une
manière de gouverner ses entreprises qui
qui va être différente en revanche il
aime prendre des risques ça c'est
certain et il aime mettre les
entreprises au bord de de la faillite ou
de la difficulté pour pour forcer pour
forcer leur destin pour aller chercher
de manière extrêmement radicale les
changements Tesla ou Space X ont failli
mourir plusieurs fois chacune d'entre
elles et vraiment failli ça s'est joué à
très très très peu de choses et avant
que Tesla devienne une entreprise qui
vaut plus que toutes les entreprises
automobiles du monde et qui a quelques
années en quelques années Tesla a failli
faire faillite plein de fois et passer
par énormément de moments où ils ont
failli ne jamais y arriver et donc et
mais en revanche il a rarement repris
des boîtes très anciennes depuis 15 ans
il a plutôt été intervenu pas forcément
créé ou intervenu très tôt dans les
entreprises dans les stratégies choc où
il littère très très vite pour essayer
de trouver une formule donc là c'est la
boîte la plus vieille entre guillemets
c'est une boîte qui est utilisée par 300
millions de personnes quoi donc ça fait
assez bizarre quand même on n'a pas
l'habitude parce qu'au début de Tesla
bon bah c'était pas très grave il y a
pas beaucoup d'utilisateurs et puis ça
avait peu de répercussions donc là il
fait ça face à quelque chose qui est
utilisé par 60 000 personnes c'est très
bizarre c'est très brutal c'est très
étonnant mais d'un certain point de vue
moi je trouve ça évidemment il y a je
suis d'accord avec les menaces notamment
sur la gouvernance sur le fait qu'il
soit seul soit le sol aux commandes et
qui est pas de gouvernance du tout des
utilisateurs et ça même si il donne des
signes actuellement de montrer qu'il est
en train d'accepter des contre-pouvoirs
open source des logiques de de librairie
tiers et cetera des logiques de
gouvernance qui me semble intéressantes
il va essayer de refaire mais là il joue
le révélateur d'un truc qui ne marchait
pas depuis longtemps qui est qui était
perdu un tout petit peu financièrement
aussi qu'il rendait mal ses services qui
n'arrivaient pas à fabriquer bien sa
modération qui n'arrivait pas à se
conformer régulation qu'on lui demandait
etc etc et donc on avait un outil qui ne
font qui grosso modo était un mauvais
équilibre un équilibre de bas niveau
merdique et lui il dit je vais casser
pour essayer de reconstruire et c'est
assez intéressant ce qui est très
inquiétant sur la manière la méthode bon
la méthode elle est violente elle est
dure mais quand une boîte est non au
bord de la faillite parfois il faut un
peu lui mettre un coup d'électrochoc
dessus il est très violent et très
américain etc en France évidemment les
gens vont être ça va être un petit peu
différent etc mais
le révélateur je pense est intéressant
mais alors il y a quand même vous dites
il prend des risques le risque il est il
est actuel écouter ce que l'architecture
technique en quelque sorte de ce réseau
social c'est ce qui explique le
professeur de droit de la concurrence
aux États-Unis s'appelle William coachi
pour maintenir un programme efficace de
protection des données et préserver
l'efficacité des mesures de protection
il faut que des équipes importantes de
personnes travaillent ensemble de
manière efficace
si vous perturbez ces équipes en
licenciant un grand nombre d'entre elles
ou en créant un environnement de lequel
un grand nombre d'entre elles
choisissent de partir vous vous
retrouvez soudain avec un sérieux
déficit d'expertise et les personnages
c'est exactement dans ce type de
circonstances que de graves défaillances
dans la sécurité des données et d'autres
caractéristiques des opérations de
l'entreprise se produisent
c'est le bon moment pour les hackers
d'aller piquer les données personnelles
sur sur les réseaux sociaux Twitter si
je comprends bien en tout cas il y a une
crainte de la part de tout un tas de
spécialistes en sécurité informatique
que le fait de de déplumer quelque part
les équipes en interne qui gèrent ces
problématiques de sécurité informatique
et bien mettre en péril un certain
nombre de systèmes de protection de sur
les serveurs sur les infrastructures
même de Twitter on voit qu'il y a
effectivement
sur les droits d'auteur par exemple il y
a des il y a des films complets qui ont
été publiés il y a tout un tiers
je pense c'est quand même un truc sur
lequel tout le monde peut se mettre
d'accord y compris Elon Musk le système
ne modération Twitter ne fonctionnait
pas twitter n'a jamais vraiment voulu
répondre
logiquement sur le nombre de modérateurs
qui existait sur la plateforme on savait
pas dans ce nombre qui était de quelques
milliers on a réussi à l'estimer à
quelques milliers à un moment donc
quelques milliers de personnes pour
mesurer ce que disent 300 millions de
personnes c'est assez dingue en fait en
proportion et surtout on voyait bien en
tant qu'utilisateur même en tant que
personnalité entre guillemets un petit
peu publique ou visible que cette
modération fonctionnait pas très bien
moi je vois assez rapidement quand je
poste un message et que je signale un
certain nombre de comptes qui me disent
des choses pas toujours très
sympathiques qu'il y a pas énormément de
choses qui est fait il y a pas beaucoup
de réactivité non et qui a postériori il
y a pas grand chose que quand on fait
des démarches judiciaires
l'autorité judiciaire française se
retrouve bloquée et n'a pas de réponse
de la part de Twitter donc il y a quand
même un truc là dessus le problème c'est
que ce qu'il a fait depuis trois
semaines c'est plutôt de supprimer la
modération que de rajouter de la
modération en l'occurrence il a expliqué
il y a quelques jours que bah ça y est
il y aurait plus de modération des
mensonges et des fake news sur le
covid-19 c'est une économie
c'est c'est assez compliqué de le dire
comme ça mais grosso modo ça joue sur
des choses qui captent mieux l'attention
et donc comme ça capte mieux l'attention
ça fait que les gens restent plus
longtemps sur la plateforme on sait
mieux qu'il vous êtes on vous cible
mieux avec des publicités cette espèce
d'horrible logique qu'on retrouve sur
tous les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
l'apanage de Twitter et bien en fait il
se va se retrouver renforcer moi ma
vraie crainte elle est que comment va se
comporter sur des questions
démocratiques essentielles un homme qui
publie des articles en expliquant par
exemple que
Hillary Clinton est morte en 2016 et
qu'elle a été remplacée par un fantôme
et par un double donc c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui va amener à ces millions
de followers sur Twitter des sources
d'information qui sont plus que
douteuses voire carrément complotistes
donc je sais bien que la liberté
d'expression américaine permet des tas
de choses que nous Français ne comprend
pas toujours mais il y a en France
la loi française qui doit primer
en tout cas ça me semble être dans un
lieu comme ici quelque chose que nous
devons dire et évidemment sur cette
question de modération témoignage
d'une utilisatrice est une étudiante
américaine voici ses ce qu'elle nous dit
sur ces craintes
il n'y a plus qu'un propriétaire ce qui
lui donne en quelques sortes tout le
pouvoir et je pense que les choses vont
probablement empirer sur Twitter s'il
essaie de donner plus de liberté
d'expression
simplement parce que cela permet aux
fausses informations de circuler au
discours haineux aux choses de ce genre
de ce produire
il risque également d'y avoir peut-être
davantage de harcèlement pour moi tout
ça c'est plutôt négatif pas à essayer
Martin la violence qui peut s'exprimer
sur Twitter cet étudiant de parler de
harcèlement elle vise aussi les
personnalités publiques donc ça c'est
une dimension qui est importante à à
signaler et à analyser est-ce que ça
fait partie des des dossiers sur
lesquels vous pourriez voilà
dans le Sénat pourrait s’emparer c'est
un point très important mais au-delà des
personnalités politiques ou
personnalités tout simplement moi je
pense qu'il faut quand même aussi que
nous-mêmes soyons un peu modérés dans
nos propos Twitter ses défauts le manque
de modération existait déjà avant en
fait on avait déjà des vrais sujets
autour du harcèlement Elon Musk ou pas
Elon Musk donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
sur lequel évidemment nous devons
travailler tout ce collectivement autour
de ça deuxième point que je voudrais
aussi partager quand même c'est que j'ai
un petit peu le sentiment que depuis
Elon Musk a racheté Twitter on se
focalise beaucoup sur sa brutalité que
vous avez très bien décrit d'un point de
vue chef d'entreprise en fait mais pour
le moment cette brutalité là hormis les
quelques tweets que vous avez signalé
complotistes et autres mais on les
connaissait déjà d'avant en fait et des
complotistes sur le réseau existe déjà
avant Elon Musk donc une fois qu'on a
bien fait qu'on a bien posé le sujet
qu'est-ce que dev pas à demain Twitter
avec quelqu'un à sa tête qui
on soupçonne moi je prends tout tes
précautions d'usage on soupçonne
effectivement lui-même de diffuser
parfois des informations qui ne sont pas
vérifiées en tant que tel donc il est
vrai que là-dessus un législateur le
législateur en France doit s'y
intéresser doit regarder ce que va
devenir Twitter en tant que tel mais moi
je vous rappelle simplement qu'il y a
déjà eu une tentative législative qui a
été faite avec la députée avia on avait
souhaité un moment donné quand je dis on
le Parlement en tout cas l'Assemblée
nationale on a vu les faiblesses en fait
et l'approche qui avait été portée à ce
moment là à tel point que le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est prononcé contre
donc il y a effectivement
encore un certain une certaine
difficulté aussi moi je le dis comme ça
de définir ce qu'est une vraie ou une
fausse aussi informations qui la
détermine
la porte et donc ça je crois que c'est
un vrai débat démocratique pour nous en
effet intéressant
notamment vous parliez des attaques sur
les personnalités publiques ou sur le
personnel politique parce que moi je
trouve que le niveau de tension de
violence au sein même de la classe
politique sur Twitter et beaucoup plus
fort aujourd'hui qu'il ne tient 5 ou 10
ans on lit des tweets de députés des
changements de gouvernance de Twitter
c'est ça que je suis là
de de l'antagonistes mais du débat
public mais qui se passe dans ce lieu là
et certains élus se permettent beaucoup
plus sur Twitter que que
non parce qu'aujourd'hui ça se on le
voit dans on parle d'ailleurs
et exactement il y a une très nette
différente et on parle même d'une forme
de twittérisation de la vie politique je
pense que vous avez totalement raison
Mathieu ces plateformes numériques elles
n'ont pas que de l'influence dans le
monde numérique et en fait vous savez ce
téléphone que nous avons entre les mains
toute la journée on le regarde en
moyenne
141 fois par jour
241 fois par jour on est connecté à ce
petit truc là 240e fois par jour on voit
le monde non plus en je suis d'accord ou
je suis pas d'accord avec vous mais je
vous aime je vous aime pas peut-être que
ce réflexe que nos cerveaux qui sont en
permanence stimulées par ces petits
algorithmes ont aussi des impacts sur la
vraie vie que la détérioration de la
qualité et du du de l'ambiance du débat
politique en France et aussi lié au fait
que nous nous informons de plus en plus
numériquement et que nos émotions sont
devenues le principal prisme était très
bien dit par mon voisin aussi un moment
donné je trouve que l'arrivée d'Elon
musk en fait relance le débat là qui
s'était un petit peu assoupi pour toutes
les raisons que vous avez évoquées c'est
qu'en fait aujourd'hui je vais le dire
comme ça la violence en fait verbale qui
peut y avoir bien sûr dans le monde
politique mais pas que mais pas que en
fait est révélatrice de quelque chose et
là le fait que Elon Musk rachète Twitter
avec la personnalité qu'il est en fait
donc avec
[Musique]
avec le DSA avec les régulations
européennes pour réaffirmer un free
speech donc et il a besoin de symboles
forts donc il vient avec des symboles
forts le vote sur Donald Trump etc et ça
donc ça le bras de fer il est très
lisible et très clair et il est très il
va poser question parce que il vient
contre des régulations européennes il
est on revient volontairement donc
les détailler mais je le je pense qu'il
le fait aussi par provocation pour
provoquer de l'échange de la discussion
de l'intérêt du débat de la surface etc
une reprisealisation qui n'avait plus
tellement lieu ok qui est par ailleurs
assez intéressant il le fait sur le mode
provocateur et il le fait aussi pour
rappeler à tout le monde que il y a pas
que la régulation qui peut marcher dans
cet univers là il s'agit de produits
qu'on design COD islow ce que je mets
dans le code comment j'organise mon
application etc est aussi très
importante et le fait de rajouter 40 000
modérateurs et peut-être moins important
que les règles qui sont dans au sein de
l'application qui sont en BD dedans etc
et que il sait aussi un problème de
design et ça aussi un problème de code
c'est aussi un problème de manière
d'organiser les choses en tout cas il a
ce point de vue très fort et ça on
l'avait un peu oublié on avait pensé
régulation régulation moyen de
modération moyenne de modération et on
avait cru que Twitter était une
institution en Europe on croyait que
c'était un peu comme un ministère etc et
qu'on allait lui appliquer les règles on
découvre on redécouvre que c'est une
entreprise qui a un produit un chiffre
design officer qui est un peu taré
et un peu mégalo et un peu je c'est moi
qui décide tout seul etc ce qui nous
pose problème et que en fait les sujets
sont un petit peu à déplacer de la
gouvernance de la régulation à la
gouvernance du design du produit et ça
je pense que ça peut interroger pas mal
le ringulateur dans les années à venir
alors justement on va parler du du
régulateur avec alexandre Poussin
notamment au niveau européen l'Union
européenne qui vient de se doter d'une
nouvelle loi pour mieux réguler les
plateformes numériques et oui cette
nouvelle loi c'est le DSA vous en
parliez le DJ tôle service aux actes en
français le règlement européen sur les
services numériques c'est le grand
chantier numérique européen depuis des
années il a été voté cette année il sera
appliqué début 2024 le principe est
simple ce qui est illégal en ligne l'est
aussi en ligne avec plusieurs objectifs
de ce règlement mieux protéger les
citoyens de la violence en ligne de la
désinformation et mieux surveiller ces
grandes plateformes concrètement ce
texte il responsabilise les plateformes
elles devront par exemple faciliter le
signalement de certains comportements
grâce à un outil visible sur
l'application retirer les propos
condamnables par la loi et puis
communiquer aux autorités à les
informations sur les auteurs de ses
propos alors ce qui est intéressant si
on rentre encore un peu plus dans le
détail c'est que ces obligations elles
varient en fonction des plateformes et
oui les règles sont encore plus strictes
pour les très grandes plateformes comme
Twitter elles doivent analyser les
risques qu'elles génèrent chaque année
sur la démocratie le bon fonctionnement
des élections ou encore les droits de
l'homme elles doivent également le
fournir les algorithmes les codes de
leurs interfaces mieux protéger les
mineurs et puis des mesures d'urgence
peuvent leur être imposées en cas de
crise comme l'éclatement d'une guerre
par exemple sur le sol européen alors
qui pas surveiller ces plateformes et
quelles sont les sanctions éventuelles
alors chaque État membre de l'Union
européenne doit mettre en place une
autorité numérique indépendante pour
surveiller ses plateformes faire
respecter ce règlement par exemple en
France c'est l'arcom qui va se charger
de cette surveillance mais pour les très
grandes plateformes numériques
internationales et bien c'est
directement la Commission européenne qui
assurera cette surveillance avec des
sanctions en cas de non-respect de ce
règlement notamment des amendes pouvant
aller jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires
des entreprises mises en cause et puis
en dernier recours une interdiction pure
et simple d'opérer en Europe donc en un
mot le cadre européen est désormais fixé
clair et ce cadre et bien le français
tiré breton le Commissaire européen en
charge de ces questions il la rappelait
Elon Musk quand Elon Musk a annoncé le
rachat Twitter avec ce fameux tweet
l'oiseau est libre Thierry Breton lui a
répondu sur Twitter oui mais en Europe
l'oiseau volera selon les règles
européennes merci Alexandre martinrak
l'Europe c'est le bon périmètre pour
pour réguler
[Musique]
les entreprises elles peuvent changer en
fait ces entreprises ne sont pas des
monolithes c'est pas l'Union soviétique
quoi c'est à dire que il faut pas une
réunion de tout le commitaire pour
décider qu'on va changer un truc il y a
la possibilité de les faire changer et
en fait je crois que musk est en train
de nous montrer qu'en fait on peut
changer les réseaux sociaux lui
l'échange en pire il en fait un outil de
division dans la démocratie on fait un
outil où il va donner la parole au plus
gros extrémistes il veut rappeler Donald
Trump qui avait été banni après avoir je
vous rappelle quand même appelé au coup
d'État dans son propre pays donc on est
quand même dans un truc qui est sidérant
quoi et ben en fait il nous montre que
ça peut changer et moi je
finalement le message
je crois qu'on on ne il y a quelque
chose qu'on ne comprend pas dans le
rapport de force que nous impose des
réseaux sociaux les médias sociaux en
réalité et bien ils ne comprennent que
le rapport de force
et donc moi il y a un truc c'est que
mais on en a déjà discuté sur ce plateau
je crois Thomas est-ce que ces médias
est-ce que c'est tuyau diffuse de
l'information oui oui la réponse est oui
comme des médias qu'ils éditorialistes
cette information est-ce que ce que vous
voyez ce que vous voyez ce que voit
Nicolas c'est la même chose non ils
éditorialise il diffuse de l'info ils
éditorisent est-ce qu'il gagne de
l'argent en le faisant oui ce ne sont
pas des tuyaux ce sont des médias il
faut donc qu'il soit responsable de ce
qu'il diffuse il suffit de changer un
décret dans la loi il y a pas besoin de
loin vient il y a pas besoin de l'Union
européenne changeons un décret monteront
au monde ce qu'est le pays des Lumières
montrant qu'en France les réseaux
sociaux seront considérés comme des
médias et qu'ils devront respecter les
mêmes règles que Public Sénat que le
monde que d'autres moi j'ai un peu peur
quand je vois ce que l'arcom n'arrive
pas à faire face à des médias
professionnels qui ont des chartes des
responsabilités des choses très
compliquées on a vu des choses ces
dernières semaines absolument aberrantes
sur des des émissions de télévision
concurrentes la Recon n'arrive pas à
agir donc il y a un moment qu'est-ce
qu'elle va faire pour cette Twitter ça
met beaucoup de temps on va dire ça
comme ça c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une
gamme de sanctions qui est progressive
la différence entre des choses qui sont
dites à la télévision et devant une
grande audience est-ce que peut avoir
comme conséquence la mécanique
diabolique des algorithmes sur un réseau
social c'est ce qu'on dit du temps
différent de la régulation de la
sanction et de la diffusion du message
c'est mille fois plus exponentiel sur un
réseau social donc je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de considérer que ce sont des
tuyaux et finalement on réglera plein de
problèmes Martin décida est-ce que c'est
aussi simple que ça parce que Thomas
nous dit il suffit d'un décret
finalement pour rendre Twitter et les
autres responsables
des propos tenus par les usagers quoi
voilà alors l'intention est bonne
l'intention est je pense partager je
crois que c'est un peu plus complexe
qu'un simple décret pour plein de
raisons vous l'avez tous rappelé il y a
346 millions d'utilisateurs Twitter
aujourd'hui aller derrière pour vérifier
à l'échelle d'un pays véritablement ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'information du
complot de l'un enfin je pense que c'est
des trucs
bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est ce qui
était je vous rappelle proposé aussi
dans le cadre législatif qui n'est pas
passé justement pour cette raison là
c'est à dire qui va définir quel est le
bon seuil en fait et donc dès lors que
c'est le média lui-même qui le fait là
il va falloir véritablement définir ce
qu'est une vraie information
non non voilà
ça c'est ça c'est de la communication
qui nous ont fait gober depuis 15 ans
c'est pas vrai
alors terminé et puis ensuite
il y a trop de tomates autour de cette
table c'est pour ça allez-y termine
votre démonstration c'est que ce n'est
pas de la volonté qui manque ce qui
manque aujourd'hui quand même un tout
petit peu et c'est la raison pour
laquelle tout à l'heure lorsque vous
posiez la question de de la
réglementation européenne je pense que
c'est le bon vecteur je pense que c'est
le bon vecteur et chaque État membre
dans ce périmètre européen peut
effectivement
amorcer plus vite pas plus vite etc on
peut en discuter mais je pense qu'il
faut que nous restions sur ce point-là
compte tenu vous le dites vous-même de
de la force de frappe que qu'il peut y
avoir à travers ces médias sociaux
il y a véritablement il faut pas que
l'on se trompe en réalité première chose
deuxième chose quand même il y a
deuxième chose que je souhaite quand
même aussi rappeler c'est que il y les
utilisateurs de Twitter eux-mêmes et je
pense qu'à ce niveau là nous même moi je
suis sur Twitter je pense qu'on est un
certain nombre autour de cette table là
il me semble qu'il est fondamental aussi
à un moment donné que l'on soit
conscient donc moi je ne suis pas en
fait
je trouve que c'est assez intéressant
finalement ce débat que l'on a en ce
moment-là parce que en tant qu'usager
moi-même je vous dis sincèrement je me
dis aujourd'hui effectivement vous voyez
en un petit peu en rigolant se dit
est-ce que à l'issue de notre débat on
va tous être blacklisté ou on va enlever
notre petit
notre petit badge bleu exactement merci
d'authentification avoir mais toujours
vérifier
le débat est réel le débat est réel donc
je dis derrière une bonne intention il
faut quand même que le vecteur soit
opérationnel c'est vraiment
l'opérationnalité de la chose qui est
importante
la parole vous dites c'est pas un média
comme les autres c'est ça non c'est pas
des c'est pas des médias comme Public
Sénat ou le monde on ne diffuse pas des
contenus sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
de sont les plateformes sur lesquelles
nous utilisateurs on a des pratiques
sociales qui passent par des échanges de
contenu et qui demande d'ailleurs dans
l'évolution des réseaux sociaux dans
logique plus interagit de metaves etc
vont être de plus en plus des pratiques
sociales donc ça n'est pas vraiment des
médias je suis désolé c'est pas juste un
média de diffusion et c'est un média de
diffusion il y a de plus en plus
d'utilisateurs pour qui c'est un média
et parfois même c'est le seul moyen de
s'informer soit médias
on y fait plein de choses on y fait
plein de choses on s'y Connect on s'y
informe on interagit on sociabilise avec
ses amis etc etc sur sur une plateforme
donc c'est bien pas un média qui diffuse
où il y a un éditeur on peut pas le
réguler comme ça et d'ailleurs c'est le
sens de la régulation du DSA qui qui est
allé quand même dans une logique assez
intelligente donc on peut pas faire
cette analogie totale évidemment c'est
d'une nature très particulière si cette
nature très particulière qu'il rend
difficile les gens font des choses un
produit séduit à un quelqu'un à Twitter
un jour il y a un mec assez malin qui
Jack Dorcy qui qui a mis ça et puis les
gens sont dit ils sont emparés ils l'ont
transformés et c'est devenu ce que c'est
devenu peu à peu notamment énormément
par l'énergie des utilisateurs qui en
ont fait quelque chose nous journaliste
que politique mais surtout monsieur
madame tout le monde sont dit mais tiens
on va détourner cet usage on va faire
quelque chose d'autre ça et donc c'est
très important quand on régule de
comprendre la pratique qui va s'y
développer qui est infiniment plus riche
que l'outil et Twitter ne peut pas tout
et plus on contraint et on essaie de se
dire on essaye de se dire c'est des
médias et on va tout réguler parce que
il n'y a que l'algorithme qui compte et
tout est dans le pouvoir etc plus on
oublie les utilisateurs et pour moi la
bonne régulation ou la bonne manière de
pacifier les pratiques elle va aussi
beaucoup dans les pratiques d'éducation
d'accompagnement de de des choses en BD
dans les plateformes à l'intérieur de
des programmes d'informations qui
luttent contre les fake news et ça et
pas une vision très externe qui se
dirait je suis en tête pour l'instant
médiatique c'est un autre pouvoir on se
parle pour l'instant c'est pas le
message que renvoie Elon Musk mais bon
les contenus la nudité par exemple les
régulée n'est extrêmement régulé puis
surtout vous faites bannir non surtout
pas qu'il s'agit de manière régulation
justement c'est le problème qui avait
soulevé Emmanuel Macron en interpellant
Elon Musk c'était comment on va protéger
compris des contenus pornographiques on
a fait des émissions ici qu'on peut
trouver sur Twitter on trouve pas sur
les autres réseaux sociaux mais sur les
autres sociaux sur les autres réseaux
sociaux le moins de contenu vous mettez
une statue elle peut vous pouvez être
banni donc ça veut dire que les moyens
sont là pour réguler après le problème
c'est qu'on a des champs ne sont pas là
et l'important c'est qu'il soit partagé
justement avec l'espace public il y a
une gouvernance tierce méta par exemple
a mis en place un overtizeboard qui a
une qui non mais qui a un pouvoir
consultatif qui travaille dessus et ça
il parle évidemment à la maison non mais
il y a des pistes qui semblent
intéressantes etc évidemment on peut
aller dedans et ils ne sont pas tout
puissants il ne faut pas croire que un
réseau social serait tout puissant sur
les contenus de manière générale il peut
imposer un certain nombre de règles il
peut imposer un certain nombre de design
mais les utilisateurs après agissent
dessus les transforme les contours etc
et donc c'est une régulation qui avance
en permanence c'est surtout un chef de
liberté d'expression parce qu'on n'a pas
la même définition à travers le monde de
la liberté
d'expressions
en France au Pays-Bas ou aux États-Unis
on n'a pas le même rapport à la nudité
pourtant son des plateformes mondiale et
donc c'est évidemment évidemment
compliqué et sans avoir américain
le droit ou la culture américaine qui
sont imposées dans la façon de justement
quand on dit la nudité bah oui la nudité
interdite en revanche des des coups de
feu des scènes violentes bah voilà c'est
un peu la même chose américaine le DSA
on vient y imposer des visions assez
européenne d'un socle commun européen de
ce que de ce qu'est une pratique sur un
réseau social et de comment on doit le
gouverner et donc je pense qu'on va dans
le bon sens avec le rgpd lDSA pour avoir
un contre-pouvoir en revanche il faut
pas oublier que ce sont des produits et
que ce sont des entreprises failliam
parce que ben voilà Twitter Twitter
était incapable ne serait pas capable
aujourd'hui de répondre au DSA en vrai
n'est pas en mesure directement
l'institution
représentant de l'intérêt des citoyens
sur notre planète qui posent le plus de
problèmes à la Silicon Valley d'ailleurs
Facebook a eu du cap-verg a dit à
plusieurs reprises que si le rgpd plus
le DSA était vraiment mis en place en
Europe il ne pourrait pas maintenir les
activités de méta sur le continent donc
ça montre bien que vous avez raison dans
le fait que ce qu'a dit Monsieur
duckermann
c'est quand même pas non plus dingue et
on sait bien que depuis la plane pour la
mais ce que j'ai c'est que je crois
qu'on peut pas se satisfaire de ces
espèces de de déclaration d'intention
qu'on a nous et de leur discours de
communication ce sont des méga
multinationales qui dominent le monde
aujourd'hui ce sont parmi les 10 plus
grandes entreprises de la planète nous
avons les cinq gafams elle n'existaient
pas il y a 20 ans ces entreprises donc
elles nous pose un problème que nous
n'avions pas auparavant même si tous
existaient avant le racisme ça existait
avant Twitter le complotisme aussi ça
existait avant Twitter mais on est
obligé de constater que tous ces
phénomènes de perturbation de la
démocratie non pas été limitées par les
réseaux sociaux elles ont été amplifiées
par ces plateformes de manière un
dernier exemple pardon de nos
interrompre un dernier exemple juste
avant de réintégrer Donald Trump Elon
Musk fait voter les utilisateurs de de
Twitter 15 millions de personnes qui
participent
51,8% répondent oui au retour de
l'ancien président américain réaction de
musk sur Twitter évidemment le peuple a
parlé on l'a vu dans le sujet tout à
l'heure la mystique commence la semaine
prochaine boxe populi boxedi Martha
Sidrac bon on peut trouver ça drôle
c'est ludique sauf que c'est de la
fausse démocratie
fausse démocratie ou pas je n'en sais
rien sincèrement sincèrement c'est pas
que je pratique la langue de bois Donald
Trump a été président de des Etats-Unis
à un moment donné il y a des Américains
on peut en penser ce qu'on veut qui ont
voté pour cet homme-là donc aujourd'hui
non parce que Elon Musk en plus ne s'est
jamais caché de ses sympathie politique
c'est une entreprise qui affiche après
je pense qu'il faut je reviens sur le
côté parodie démocratie on sait Thomas
il y a des robots il y a des 11 millions
de personnes des vraies personnes déjà
ça on aimerait bien le savoir à mon avis
pardon je vais terminer c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense il faut que nous
fassions attention au contour réel et je
pense que ce que met en place l'Union
européenne on peut en penser ce qu'on
veut on peut penser que ça assez vite et
assez fort mais je pense que c'est le
bon vecteur je me répète pardonnez-moi
parce qu'il est nécessaire en réalité
qu'on s'intéresse véritablement au
contenu les mesures justement que
l'oignon l'Union européenne mais en
place pour le protéger en fait l'espace
européen et donc le citoyen européen et
pour moi c'est vraiment ça en réalité le
vrai chemin à prendre aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup on va terminer là-dessus le
débat est terminé
ça prouve que c'était dans ce je
rappelle le titre de votre livre Thomas
échanti fake news écrit co écrit avec
Jean-Bernard Schmitt et donc publié aux
éditions First merci à tous encore une
fois d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat
je vous dis à demain et votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
bonjour chez vous on vient de Monsigny
reçoit Sébastien Chenu député du Nord
vis président du Rassemblement national
belle soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]